bonjour à tous bienvenue c'est l'heure
de par le break tôt avec à mes côtés
kathia gilder bonjourbonjour michael est
notre invité cette semaine jean marc
germain
bonjour vous êtes députée socialiste des
hauts-de-seine proche de martine aubry
beaucoup d'actualité pour vous à
l'assemblée notamment
oui notamment parce que les députés
poursuivent l'examen du budget 2010
cette majorité et opposition ont décidé
d'utiliser l'hémicycle comme une tribune
politicienne et on reviendra sur la
colère des policiers qui ont une
nouvelle fois bravé l'interdiction de
manifester un peu partout en france
françois hollande recevant une
délégation de policiers la semaine
prochaine depuis je mange un rat on vous
écoutera également sur ces socialistes
yoonu doute françois hollande peut-il
être candidat à la présidentielle les
effets du livre un président pauthe il
dire ça n'ont pas fini de diviser cette
majorité
mais d'abord la semaine marquée par
cette colère des policiers qui s'étend
sur le territoire
ils ont manifesté une fois de plus un
peu partout en france et dans plusieurs
villes de province pour dire leur ras le
bol d'être pris pour cible et victimes
d'agressions françois chevret chez les
policiers
c'était la semaine de la colère des
manifestations nocturnes des forces de
l'ordre ont eu lieu partout en france
comme ici à paris
pourtant mercredi le gouvernement à
tenter de renouer le dialogue
bernard cazeneuve a reçu les syndicats
de police il leur a promis des renforts
d'effectifs en essonne là où un policier
a été grièvement blessé il ya deux
semaines il a également lancé une
concertation entre les préfets les
policiers dès lundi prochain
elle permettra d'écouter les personnels
et d'engager avec eux un dialogue riche
sur les sujets suivants la dotation de
la sécurité publique en nouveau matériel
dès 2017
la question des charges indues
l'amélioration des conditions de travail
par l'engagement de travaux immobiliers
notamment les conclusions de cette
concertation ne seront remises en
décembre pour une mise en oeuvre
immédiate dès le début de 2010 est
mais c'est chez le garde des sceaux que
les syndicats avaient le plus d'attentes
jean jacques urvoas va envoyer une
circulaire aux magistrats leur demandant
d'être plus sévère contre les personnes
qui attaquent les policiers
'l'annonce satisfait certains syndicats
elle est insuffisante pour d'autres
l'outrageuse le crash à l'écrit bien
évidemment qui plus est les coups portés
doit faire l'objet aujourd'hui de
sanction exemplaire
pour le moment peu d'effets sur les
policiers une marche de la colère
policière est citoyenne est toujours
prévue mercredi prochain
alors françois hollande va recevoir une
délégation de policiers la semaine
prochaine faut-il compter sur lui pour
calmer cette colère des policiers
en tout cas je crois qu'il faut entendre
la colère des policiers parce que elle
correspond à une réalité à une
inquiétude d'ailleurs tous les français
ont été frappés par ces images de ces
policiers brûlé dans une voiture de
police en essonne mais moi je pense
qu'il faut que les français soient
auprès auprès des policiers l'en j'ai
bien vu qu'il ya une polémique sur
est-ce qu'on peut défiler ou pas en
uniforme je crois qu'il faut la mettre
entre parenthèses
même si c'est très grec
public n est importante c'est à dire
parce qu'il faut il faut d'abord se
concentrer sur les raisons de cette
colère
donc c'est mélanie feist ils se disent
ils sont pas dans les clous de la loi
quand ils ont leurs uniformes ou leur
arme quand ils utilisent leur véhicule
de police mais je crois que si on fait
une polémique sur cette question là on
va oublier qu'il ya des policiers qui
ont été agressés mois je souhaiterais
que photos que les effets faire les
laisser manifester laisser aller et
frier cette colère il faut régler les
difficultés qu'il qu'il soulève
je crois que c'est très important vous
savez moi je garde en tête l'image de la
liesse des français de la reconnaissance
envers les forces de police quand il
c'est grande manifestation après les
attentats je crois qu'il faut garder ça
il faut que les françaises soit vous
garder en soutien de leur police je
marquerai ce que vous gardez en tête
aussi le fait que lionel jospin en 2002
et est éliminé sur cette question de la
sécurité est ce que c'est une bombe à
retardement aujourd'hui pour le
gouvernement
écoutez moi mais moi je veux pas rentrer
dans cela c'est une vraie question quand
même entre encore un petit peu dans
cette question politique ou oui mais si
on rentre dans cette question politique
moi j'ai par exemple le premier
secrétaire formation politique à
laquelle j'appartiens a vu derrière cela
une manipulation du front national moche
en total désaccord avec cette
déclaration qu'il a pu faire et je la
regrette parce que moi en politique je
veux que les français soient en soutien
de l'or de leurs polices et court se
concentre sur sa non venue réjoui que le
président de la république que c'est
symbolique d'être reçus à l'elysée marx
symbole la transition lycée miroir le fn
derrière tout cela et est une faute
politique de la partie christophe hier
une conférence de presse pour dénoncer
cela était une erreur politique oui et
moi je regrette cela je veux vraiment
que l'on soit en soutien de nos forces
de police et que on écoute les policiers
qui expriment des craintes et qui ont
des demandes de soutien de meilleurs
véhicules de police d équipement de
de protection justement ce qui demande
des moyens alors est-ce que vous pensez
que gouvernement françois ans peut
encore lui accorder leur accorder des
moyens davantage de moyens ont déjà tout
eh oui je crois et je crois qu'ils
doivent arriver le plus vite possible
que ce soit des gilets par la balle que
ce soit des véhicules plus performant
que ce soit aussi parce que là on parle
pas du terrorisme puisque cette affaire
dans l'essonne n'était pas une affaire
de terrorisme mais il ya aussi la
question de la formation des policiers
au au maniement des armes de guerre dont
ils sont désormais dotés voilà on a fait
beaucoup d'efforts pour renforcer les
effectifs de police et de gendarmerie
et tant mieux celle inverse de ce qui
s'était passé avant mais il faut il faut
continuer c'est essentiel dans un état
de droit qui nous police pour assurer le
maintien de l'ordre et je crois qu'il
faut vraiment être en soutien malek
boutih que vous connaissez député
socialiste parle d'un plan anti racaille
dans les banlieues est ce que là dessus
sur ses termes qui leur propose est
d'accord avec lui non je suis en total
désaccord
aussi je crois que la situation amène
beaucoup de responsabilités politiques
je regrette aussi c'est un manque de
responsabilité politique que ce soit
jean christophe cambadelis mais je
voudrais vous auriez pu aussi citer les
responsables politiques de droite qui
préfèrent voilà mais je veux pas le
faire justement moi j'appelle chacun à
être encore barry nicolas sarkozy parla
bernard cazeneuve par médias interposés
qu'est ce qui se passe que ce à quoi ça
ressemble pour vous écoutez moi j'ai
entendu le ministre de l'intérieur
quelqu'un de grande qualité qui est
quelqu'un qui défend ces policiers
jusqu'au bout j'entendais par exemple
pour vous citer un nom
monsieur estrosi ce matin sur une feinte
de radio radio et qui mettait en cause
le ministre de l'intérieur en disant
qu'il aurait pour la première fois porté
plainte contre un agent
de police alors qu'en réalité il faisait
référence à la sphère de la policière
municipale de nice qu'elle met en cause
2010 la danse c'est ça qu'il faut éviter
c'est en tout cas ce qu'annonce la
république c'est ce qu'ont en commun la
droite et la gauche
on est tous responsables consensus sur
cette question de de soutenir un police
pilier de la république qui est qu il
que sont les forces de l'ordre quand des
polypus bidons les polémiques là oui
justement quand des policiers
manifestent comme ils le font
régulièrement c'est quand même le signe
que la république ne va pas très bien
c'est le signe vraiment d'un choc très
fort qu'ils ont eu
vous savez il ya eu à traiter de cas pas
eu des manifestations mais il ya eu
aussi quelque chose qui les a beaucoup
bouleversée c'est qu'en deux d'entre eux
ont été assassinés à leur domicile par
un terroriste moi j'avais fait à ce
moment là le tour des commissariats de
ma circonscription il y avait eu déjà un
grand traumatisme donc faut être avec
eux il faut leur donner les moyens
compris le message
on a fait beaucoup la droite avait
failli sur ce plan là mais il faudra
continuer moi je souhaite qu'on porte ça
en commun la gauche et la droite c'est
très important
allez on va passer du côté de
l'assemblée nationale va pas ce qui
s'est passé cette semaine sur le budget
alors ce budget concrétise les promesses
de baisses notamment d'impôt qu'avait
promis le gouvernement des cadeaux des
surprises aussi ont été accordés vous
allez voir notamment aux pme maïté
frémaux ont fait ce résumé coup de
théâtre hier soir dans l'hémicycle alors
que la baisse de l'impôt sur les
sociétés tient le haut du pavé
c'est un revirement inattendu du côté du
gouvernement
dans sa version initiale l'exécutif
proposait qu'une entreprise de moins de
50 millions de chiffre d'affaires qui
réalise un bénéfice de 75 mille euros
voit sa facture d'impôt sur le revenu
passer de 25000 à 21000 euros en 2017
mais pour karine berger et valérie
rabault cet allégement devrait être
proposée à toutes les pme en 2019 et
2020 il ne dépend que de vous de lever
ce gage nous pouvons ce soir
sortir avec un amendement qui permet à
partir de 2019 2020 de m lles des
entreprises des pme à 15 % tout en
gardant peut-être le dispositif que vous
voulez sur les grandes entreprises
d'abord contre cette extension michel
sapin créé la surprise
le ministre des finances accepte et
soutient cette proposition c'est ça le
double objectif de cet amendement le
maintien des 28 % pour tous en 2019 2020
et une progression de la vente âge pour
les petites entreprises
en 2019 un coup de pouce pour plus de
3,4 millions de pme également adopté à
droite de l'hémicycle vous savez très
bien qu'entre maintenant et 2019 2020
tout peut être revu les allégements
prévus pour les grandes entreprises
elles ne sont pas remises en cause pour
charles de courson
c'est de la poudre aux yeux qu'est-ce
qu'ils aient changé par rapport à votre
projet d'article en 2017 d'après je
comprends rien rien c'est intéressant
c'est un gag
reste à savoir si cet engagement pourra
être tenu à l'origine
l'article du projet de loi de finances
représentait déjà un impact budgétaire
de 7 milliards d'euros à l'horizon 2020
je vois que jamais on a vu que cette
fois les frondeurs les socialistes
avaient gagné quelques petites victoires
par ci par là est ce que ça veut dire
que le gouvernement a décidé de lâcher
du lest je pense que les parlementaires
ont décidé de prendre les choses en main
plus
qu'il ne le faisait et au delà même des
frondeurs puisque vous montriez valérie
rabault karine berger sur partie gros
ces deux parlementaires et c'est une
très bonne nouvelle et le ministre les
écoute tant mieux il ya deux autres
amendements qui ont été adoptées qui
sont très importants et à la création de
la taxe sur les transactions financières
pour les transactions intra day baisser
ces mouvements spéculatifs de très court
terme qui était écartée jusqu'ici ces
abus les actions les obligations et puis
le taux de cette taxe a été augmenté de
0,1
vous expliquiez 0,3 n'ont que peu de
caméras on vous n'arrivez pas à obtenir
ce que vous vouliez puis la veille
d'élections
allez on lâche tout je pense que les
parlementaires ont pris conscience
qu'ils avaient un pouvoir supérieur à
celui qu'il donc c'est la victoire des
parlementaires sur le gouvernement
pas une victoire parce que moi aussi
j'ai toujours dit le gouvernement c'est
le gouvernement de la france
même quand il ya certaines idées que je
ne partageais pas ah oui on vous a connu
plus critiques comme ça non non j'ai dit
le gouvernement c'est le gouvernement de
la france donc il peut reprendre des
idées par exemple de droite mais le
parlementaire socialiste et porte une
histoire il porte des idées y portent
des engagements auprès des français et
ce qui m'a toujours choqué c'est qu'à la
fin on se sent s'en remettent au
gouvernement j'ai créé un livre qui
s'appelle tout avait si bien commencé
mais quel journal d'un parlementaire et
qui dit que notre responsabilité c'est
que quand on n'est pas d'accord on le
dit et on assume dans son vote j'étais
pas d'accord sur la loi elle comme rri
s'il m'avait donné la possibilité de la
beauté
j'aurais voté contre dont ces îles
conséquent la brossette quoi pour ce
budget vous dites que vous pouvez
discuter que la discussion se passe bien
donc il y aura une bonne majorité pour
voter ce budget ans au mois de novembre
la discussion est tendu parce que je
fais pas facile on est sous la vème
république la transit la tradition c'est
que le gouvernement décide de tout et
que le parlementaire veut la loi de
finance de la majorité veulent tout ce
qu'on lui dit la ja vous l'avez vu dans
les débats ça a été parfois tendus mais
il ya eu une écoute et je trouve c'est
une bonne façon de fonctionner coûté si
la copie que mais le gouvernement sur la
table du parlement ressort de manière
identique à quoi sert le parlement alors
même que
il ya moi j'ai découvert ça c'était mon
premier mandat il ya vraiment une grande
capacité de travail d'analysé des
problèmes et une grande intelligence
collective au parlement et je pense que
si on fait confiance au parlement
le ce pays a beaucoup mieux et ce que je
dis ça vaut pour nous les socialistes
pour nous la gauche mais ça vaut aussi
pour ceux du camp d'en face mais on voit
comme qu'il ya un peu des enjeux de ce
budget se discute sur fond d'enjeux de
campagne vous vous le ressentez aussi
quand même si c'est assez clair je sais
pas moi je prends très au sérieux ce
qu'on fait et je trouve que c'est bien
que y ait des amendements importants des
parlementaires qui sont votées on va
aussi voter la semaine prochaine un
amendement pour baisser la csg sur les
retraités modestes parce que dans les
décisions fiscales qu'on a pris de fait
acté le gouvernement américaine rihanna
oui mais ça a été un bras de fer en
rallye mais oui c'est pour ça que vous
gagnez les bras de fer et bien tant
mieux
enfin je j'allais donc eu aucune raison
pour que ce budget ne soit pas votée
c'est quelque chose qui va engager
aujourd'hui des gens continuent sur
cette voie excellente je dis bravo
je vous parlais de la taxe sur les
transactions financières à quoi elle va
servir parce qu il pas juste pour se
faire plaisir ou pour taxer ça va
diminuer la spéculation et ça va
financer l'aide au développement de
manière très fort et avec eux le budget
servira revenu intermédiaire quand on
est parle d'un vert vis-à-vis du
gouvernement on a obtenu avec ce travail
là qui est 280 millions d'euros de plus
pour l'aide au développement
c'est aujourd'hui pour le sahel c'est 30
millions d'euros
si on est capable de mettre ça et
d'avoir un effet levier on va commencer
à s'attaquer vraiment aux problèmes du
sahel et donc au problème de la pauvreté
et donc fois cette migration
c'est louable mais d'un autre côté ce
que cette taxe ne va pas pénaliser les
banques et donc la pl paris qui espère
quand même prendre la place de londres
comme première place financière d'europe
et scully les banques voient d'un très
mauvais oeil cette taxe non elle va
envoyer un signal clair aux marchés
financiers ont dit oui à la finance qui
sert à l'économie et non à la finance
qui est au service d'elle-même
j'aimerais vous savez la finance
elle-même pourquoi elle va finalement
venir à paris parce qu'elle sait très
bien que c'est pas durable l'économie et
malgré cette taxe qu'il ya un moment il
ya des ja et tout le monde perse il n'y
a pas de réalité économique derrière
donc voilà on envoie ce message la
future mais j'avais cet axe 0 3%
c'est être con mais aller au royaume uni
0,5 défavorisés dans la future majorité
quelle qu'elle soit ce qu'elle sera
attaché tenu par ce budget 2010 est je
pense qu'il est de bonne pratique dans
la république que l'on ne dépasse pas
tout ce qu'on fait les majorités
précédente mais en même temps matic et
pas vraiment le parlement est souvent
ainsi il ya des choses que la majorité
futur souhaite corriger qu'elle le fasse
mais en ayant essayé de comprendre ce
qui a été fait par les prédécesseurs
j'espère qu'on se succèdera à nous mêmes
même si on part de loin
alors on va ouvrir notre séquence
politique avec scooter qui fait produit
chez les verts michèle rivasi et yannick
jadot se sont qualifiés pour le second
tour de la primaire cécile duflot a été
éliminée dès le premier tour
grosse déception donc pour l'ancien
ministre et secrétaire nationale des
verts est ce que pour vous jean marc
germain
cécile duflot a encore un avenir
politique et écouter d'abord
félicitations end jadot et michèle
rivasi disons à une primaire les choses
n'était pas joué d'avancé c'est la
compétition qui donne le résultat c'est
pour ça que moi je souhaite la question
du maire à gauche
non parce que moi je ne savait pas sur
quel fondement alors même qu' il y avait
plus de 8000 personnes qui n'étaient pas
des adhérents écologistes donc que les
écologistes ne connaissait pas on
pouvait dire que telle ou telle était
favori
maintenant je vais aussi avoir un
message d'amitié pour cécile duflot
parce que beaucoup travaillé avec elle
notamment quand elle est redevenue
parlementaire c'est une personne de
qualité j'imagine que ça doit être dur
pour elle alors qu'elle s'imaginait
compte tenu qu'on continue l aventure et
puis deuxième chose que je veux dire
c'est que nous les socialistes ou tout
cas nous les aubrystes on vous demandera
le candidat qui sortira vainqueur de
cette primaire comme à nouveau
partenaire vous savez qu'on organise le
26 novembre - ce qu'on a appelé un
carrefour des gauches et des écologistes
sont bien évidemment invités parce qu'il
faut au delà du choix des candidats pour
la présidentielle discuter dès
maintenant sur le programme
du prochain quinquennat et nous nous
souhaitons que ça se fasse avec toutes
les formations de gauche écrit avec avec
europe écologie voilà sur deux noms sur
ces nouvelles bases qui a quand même de
nouvelles bases sur le avec l'accord
législatif éventuellement oui bien sûr
nous nous souhaitons cela et c'est pour
ça que nous organisons ce carrefour ce
premier carrefour des gauches et de
l'écologie et qui en amènera d'autres
est-ce que vous souhaitez vous qu'il y
ait un candidat d'europe écologie les
verts à l'élection présidentielle
autonome coûteux c'est pas à nous de le
décider
moi j'ai souhaité qu'il ya un candidat
unique de la gauche
j'ai signé tous les appels qui voulait
une primaire de toutes les formations de
gauche parce que je crois que c'est une
combinaison décidé d'y aller seul
visiblement maintenant je constate que
chacun décide d'y aller seul jean-luc
mélenchon europe ecologie les verts
je crois qu'il faut aussi respecter ce
choix là si nous voulons travailler
ensemble demain on va revenir un peu
votre parti d'ambiance était
particulièrement entendu cette semaine
au groupe socialiste à l'assemblée
oui le doute s'est emparée des élus
socialistes ils souhaitent des
explications après les révélations dans
le livre un président ne devrais pas
dire ça regardez ce sujet de jean
baptiste daoulas leur soutien à françois
hollande n'est plus automatique
depuis la publication des confessions du
président plusieurs députés lui demande
de s'expliquer c'est une évidence que ce
livre n'a pas été compris et qu'ils
forment désormais que le président s'en
explique et que depuis se rassurer sur à
la fasse attention et sur les
perspectives qui le fixe et seul sage
que je souhaite c'est que il avant son
calendrier qu'ils disent avec
détermination qu'il est candidat parce
que c'est quand même celui qui rassemble
le plus dans notre camp des députés
déstabilisé par l'attitude du président
de la république et déjà certains parmi
les proches du premier ministre n'hésite
plus à évoquer une candidature de manuel
valls pour remplacer françois hollande y
compris le président la république ni si
j'avais pas manuel pourrait être en
position d'y aller ah voilà je pense que
ça amène à éventuellement à y réfléchir
tout simplement
françois hollande n'a pas prévu
d'interventions médiatiques pour
s'expliquer cette semaine à l'assemblée
ses proches en sont réduits à demander à
chacun de garder son sang froid quand on
est député
quand on est concentré sur l'essentiel
c'est à dire l'action au service des
français on tremble pas on ne s'émeut
pas à l'idée que paraîtrait un livre qui
n'est qu'un livre le meilleur livre qui
fait le récit du quinquennat c'est le
journal officiel de la république
française celui qui consignent les
décrets les lois qui ont été adoptés
depuis quatre ans et demi au service du
peuple français
malgré la pression croissante des
militants et des élus socialistes
françois hollande reste imperturbable
pas question pour le président de
s'exprimer sur sa candidature avant le
mois de décembre aux nombreuses
questions évidemment très politique à
vous poser mais j'ai une question par
rapport aux libyens vous êtes en train
de lire visiblement heureux s'est
entretenu ensemble là dessus est ce que
vous faites toujours confiance au
président de la république après elle et
quelques pages de lecture de ses livres
de ce pas un livre qui va me faire
changer
faire pencher mon avis d'un côté ou de
l'autre
je pense que dans ce livret est
problématique pour un certain nombre de
questions je comprends bien
l'exercice auquel il a voulu se livrer
et qui éloigne c'est à dire mettre des
journalistes au coeur du pouvoir pour
qu'il puisse suivre les choses savoir
comment les décisions se prennent en
france mais en même temps il ya des
choses effectivement qui ne devrait pas
être dit
concernant la conduite de l'état pour la
préservation des intérêts français
vous avez aussi à quelques éléments
aussi rencontré politique
oui mais ça vous savez c'est un peu la
vie politique on peut se lâcher entre
guillemets dans un dîner avec des
journalistes
alors j'ai une question beaucoup plus
précis le drame étaient bouclées précise
dans l'audi ville est souvent référence
au fait du choix de martine aubry quand
en 2011 le fait qu'elle n'ait pas été
premier ministre il aurait pu le devenir
finalement c'est l'impression qu'il ya
des regrets de la part de françois
hollande
écoutez alors sur ce plan un champ total
désaccord avec en total accord par d'art
avec ce qui me semble à travers les 40
premières pages que j'ai lu c'est que je
pense que j'écris ça dans mon livre tout
avait si bien commencé c'est que le
choix dit s'est trompé sur son choix du
premier premier ministre n'ont pas que
jean marc ayrault n'est pas un homme de
qualité mais c'est que martine aubry
parce qu'elle avait portée elle était la
chef de l'opposition helle devenait le
chef naturel de la majorité
elle était celle qu'avait écrit le
projet socialiste qui était devenu le
projet présidentiel
elle était dans la position idéale pour
l'incarner et enfin elle était une
personnalité politique recommandé
reconnu par les français depuis
longtemps avec son poids politique
preuves et elle aurait permis au
président de la république de président
et comme il l'avait souhaité dans sa
femme le cirad donc je pense qu'il a
commis une erreur à ce moment là et je
découvre effectivement dans le livre
qu'il a l'air lui-même de s'interroger
sur cela est ce qu'aujourd'hui au vu de
sa et dans ces conditions françois
hollande est encore en mesure de se
présenter à l'élection présentielle vous
en pensez quoi vous écoutez moi je suis
très pragmatique je me suis battu pour
qu'on les ait un processus qui
choisissent notre candidat les primaires
ça a été décidé par le parti socialiste
et bien maintenant je considère que
toutes les candidatures sont légitimes
perso c'est à dire que si le président
de la république souhaite se présenter
et il est tout à fait fondé de son point
de vue à le faire et j'ajoute une fois
que j'ai dit ça que pour l'instant pour
moi aucun des candidats soient déclarés
soit supposé ne s'impose naturellement
c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que notre
primaire sera utile qu'est ce qu'est ce
qu'on va faire les différents candidats
quand chacun des atouts quand chacun des
idées intéressantes mais quand chacun
aussi des pentes à remonter c'est à la
fois d'avoir un projet pour la france
pour l'instant on commence à en
connaître ces france en tant que leader
naturel et deuxièmement à reconquérir le
coeur des français parce qu'aucun
d'entre eux ne l'a conquis pour
l'instant donc s'étendant en déroulant
ses propositions en les expliquant
montrant la capacité de convaincre les
français qu'on verra moi je ne gêner
aucun candidat l'heure où je vous parle
qu'est-que que j'ai l'intention que je
voudrais soutenir si je vais écouter ce
que les arbres et les autres vont dire
pendant la primaire
et je me déterminerai vers la mi janvier
justine va va aller plus loin justement
avec vous et avec notre partenaire du
figaro.fr tout de suite
jim brass et c'est à vous bonjour
bonjour jean marc germain alors vous
venez nous dire que vous déterminerez la
mi-janvier sur votre candidat à soutenir
pour la présidentielle pourtant dès le
mois de septembre on a entendu martine
aubry dont vous êtes proche esquissé un
rapprochement avec françois hollande en
louant une partie de de son bilan et en
lançant un appel au rassemblement de la
gauche est ce que ça veut dire que la
publication des confessions de françois
hollande a changé la donne et qu'au
final le le soutien qui semblait
s'esquisser 1 et n'est plus d'actualité
non ça veut dire que ce soutien qui
semble s exquis et ses ex qui séné était
une interprétation de ses propos
martine aubry vous savez là un avantage
c'est qu'elle dit ce qu'elle pense de
tout simplement donc c'est pas à peine 2
des ce cri de décrypter ce qu'elle a
voulu dire
elle a fait une intervention à
l'université d'été de rentrer à lille où
elle a dit pour moi ce qui compte c'est
les idées avant les hommes depuis autour
d'elle on travaille à mettre en forme
ses idées c'est pour ça qu'on organise
ce carrefour des gauches et de
l'écologie ensuite on verra ce qu'en
font les différents candidats justement
quand on prendra notre décision donc
martin nombre est exactement dans la
même réflexion que celle que je vous
décrivais elle n'a pas fait de choix de
candidats alors ne se déterminera pas
attendre savoir ce que les amalgames
injustes parce que c'est important ce
que vous dites
en un mot est ce que si françois
hollande ne va pas est ce que vous
excluez totalement le fait que martine
aubry depuis ciel et coûte elle l'a dit
elle même dit qu'elle est candidate au
débat d'idées aux propositions aider son
pays à se relever mais elle ne sera pas
candidate aux primaires donc je suis en
fait dans tous les cas de figure je
respecte parfaitement ce choix c'est
elle qui est là et qu'il n'a formulé
même si moi je pense qu'elle ferait une
très bonne candidate je comprends
parfaitement les raisons politiques pour
lesquelles elle ne le fait pas jim même
si manuel valls par exemple se présente
on se retrouve avec une situation
potentiellement avec la candidature de
manuel valls et d'emmanuel macron on
connaît
le sentiment que porte martine aubry
vis-à-vis de ces deux personnalités
ça ne changerait pas la donne emmanuel
macron n'est pas candidat aux primaires
socialistes benoît hamon arnaud
montebourg est peut-être le président de
la république ou le premier ministre
nous nous n'avons de ressentiment contre
personne parce que ce qu'on dit à
martine aubry supporter par arnaud
montebourg et c'est notre seul souci
c'est de savoir ce qui est bon pour la
france
est ce que vont proposer les uns et les
autres et ce qui est conforme à la
primaire c'est pour ça les idées avant
les hommes c'est très simple on sait
vraiment ce qu'on pense et je fais pas
de penser on le construire en
contribuant des petits arnaud montebourg
par exemple remporté la primaire vous le
soutiendrait bien sûr quel que soit le
candidat qui sait qu'un seul camp des
mers parce que moi je suis très clair je
peux besogneux peut-être dans mon
approche de la politique je lis les
programmes de la droite est jolie la
programme de la gauche quelle que soit
d'ailleurs le candidat de la gauche avec
leur différence c'est c'est le jour et
la nuit
la retraite à 65 ans l'augmentation sans
augmentation de salaire moi je n'en veux
pas on parle même de l'hypothèse
ségolène royal qui revient cette semaine
est-ce que c'est plausible est-ce que
c'est souhaitable pour moi toutes les
candidatures devront être examinés avec
résumait de celle ci et je vous vois
sourire mais je suis très sérieux dans
ceux là je crois que on a des femmes et
des hommes qui ont leurs qualités leurs
défauts nature y est mais non c'est pour
ça qu'on a choisi un processus pour le
trouver qui est la primaire c'est à dire
ça veut dire aussi que leur prêtent à
ses fans filles ou femmes et aux hommes
de gauche
la possibilité de le faire avec nous
dernière question vous l'avez dit vous
réunissez le 26 novembre a bondi pour le
carrefour des gauches ces quatre jours
seulement avant l'ouverture des
candidatures à la primaire est ce que
finalement ce n'est pas trop tard
justement pour influer sur les
programmes des candidats et fait porter
vos idées comme vous le souhaitez ce que
vous souhaitez le faire
non je crois que pour l'instant les
français sont plutôt à regarder la
primaire de droite ont pas beaucoup
d'espacé politique pour les débats à
gauche et donc on a souhaité s'inscrire
après ce processus là qui sera saine aux
primaires elle commence le 1er décembre
blad d'un dépôt de candidature jusqu'au
15 et ensuite les débats c'est à partir
du 15 donc on est dans le timing
et puis vous savez on avait envisagé
dans un premier temps de le faire à la
fin du mois d'août de l'annoncé fin
juillet on ya renoncé à cause des
attentats nice parce qu'il nous semblait
qu'on était dans un moment d'unité
nationale et pas de débat policé
mcgregor et la seconde est serez-vous
candidat aux futures législatives ou pas
tg pas pris ma décision je fais les
choses dans l'ordre
j'ai fait des bilans de mandat je le
rencontre les habitants de ma
circonscription je leur dis que j'ai pas
fait mon choix je vois s'il souhaite que
je me représente ou pas et en fonction
de ça en fonction aussi de la
structuration du débat politique de ma
capacité et positivement je ferai mon
choix fin novembre eh bien merci jean
march à mende avoir été l'invité de
parlement hebdo on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine une semaine à tous
mega